- We are back here with
actor-extraordinaire,
but also a "Bachelor" superfan,
Topher Grace, everybody!
- I'm happy to-
(audience cheering)
I'm happy to say, Jesse asked me,
and I am going to be the next "Bachelor"!
(Drew cheering)
(Jesse cheering)
Yes!
(audience cheering)
Wow! I can't believe it!
- But also, the extraordinary
host of "The Bachelor",
Jesse Palmer is here.
- Thank you so much
for having me.
(audience cheering)
Thank you.
- Gracing us, pun intended,
with his presence.
Okay, what is your favorite part
about hosting "The Bachelor"?
- Well, it's way less
stressful being the host
than it is actually being "The Bachelor",
because you don't have to worry about
dealing with all the drama.
You don't have to deal with
breaking people's hearts,
calling out the wrong
name at rose ceremonies.
Like somebody once upon a time did.
(audience laughing)
- I cannot imagine what it's
like to be "The Bachelor".
I really can't.
Jesse, do you think that
we even ask a bachelor?
'Cause we do have another
surprise for Topher.
- We do, listen,
- What's going on?
- I mean, obviously, I was "The Bachelor".
It was a long time ago.
You were probably just
a kid when it happened
but there is someone
I can think of.
- Who?
- A certain Mr. Clayton Echard
- You would.
- Maybe, everybody?
- Yes.
- "The Bachelor" now,
- The actual-
- Clayton Echard, there he is!
(Drew cheering)
(audience cheering)
(Drew screaming)
- Clayton Echard,
- Topher.
- You're here!
- Topher, Drew,
yeah, Jesse.
- You know, Drew thinks
this is a prank on me,
but this is actually
just a prank on my wife.
(Jesse laughing)
(audience laughing)
- Well, I was gonna say Ashley Grace,
how you doing?
(Drew screaming)
I wanna shout her out as well.
- Oh man, Clayton, just
give us a hint, man.
Give us a hint.
(Drew inhaling sharply)
- Do you want me to wink
one time if this happened,
or wink twice for another?
(Topher laughing)
Listen, I'm doing well overall.
I heard you said you hadn't
seen "The Women Tell All".
Buckle up for that one.
I had to do that, to say the least.
- Are you very happy
in your life right now?
- I am a happy man.
Yes.
- Yeah? Okay.
I've learned a lot of lessons,
and I'm better than I was when
I came in, as a human being.
- Clayton for you,
having been a "Bachelor",
and now that, or being on both
sides of it, I should say,
what do you like best about
being in the driver's seat?
And what's the worst thing about it?
- Oh, Jesse alluded to it. I'll start off.
I always wanna end on a good note,
so let me start off with what was tough,
was the lack of control.
I had a little bit,
but not nearly as much as
what I thought at times,
and I had to be able to sit back
and just tell myself, "Hey,
roll with the punches.
Do what you can. Be your authentic self.
And at the end of the day, if you do that,
you won't look back and have regrets".
Even though I made mistakes,
I mean, it's so very
apparent as everyone's seen,
and I accept full responsibility
for those actions.
But with that, again, I
think the best part about it
is I've been able to
grow as an individual.
I think I had five years of growth
that packed into two months,
and for that I'm so very thankful.
I built so many great connections,
and for that, again,
it's like I'm just happy
to have been able to go through it.
- I'd love to ask
(audience applauding)
Clayton, Jesse, and Topher,
as a woman, if I could
hear your deal breakers,
what is one thing you cannot
live without in a woman?
What is one thing you
can't live with a woman?
Clayton, you start please.
- (sighs) Sense of humor is
right there up at the top.
So I look for somebody that can make me
laugh on a daily basis, and
someone that's a little weird.
I like weirdness.
It just makes me, it's unique,
and keeps me on my toes.
So that's something I look for.
Something that frustrates me,
is, it's kind of just, I think,
what everybody else would say,
as far as someone who's rude or impatient,
something along those lines.
I think I just want someone
who's understanding,
and that's critical
more than anything else.
- Okay. Good to know.
(audience applauding)
Good to know for the last three ladies.
Jesse, what about you?
What is a must have, and
what's a deal breaker?
- I'm real big on family values,
and it doesn't hurt if you
make great chocolate brownies.
(audience laughing)
I think if, a deal breaker for me would be
if you were inconsiderate.
I think for me, that that's a big one.
That would probably be it for me.
- You stole mine, dude.
I would actually, I would,
kind of the same thing as you.
- Brownies?
- Yeah, brownies.
- Oh.
(Drew laughing)
(audience laughing)
- No, but I think, respect for others.
- What is-
- I went on a date, early on,
where someone was really
rude to the waiter,
and I just thought like,
(Drew gasping)
but she was being really
nice to me, and I thought,
"That's not cool.
- No.
This person's actually
serving us", you know?
You gotta be, it was
a great telltale sign.
- Yeah, and a must-have?
- Everything that Ashley
Grace is. (chuckles)
(Jesse laughing)
(audience applauding)
- [Clayton] Smart man, smart man.
- Jesse and Clayton, thank you so much
- Of course, man.
- That was great.
- for gracing us
- Thank y'all so much.
- With your time
and your presence.
And Topher, your amazing
show, "Home Economics"
is every Wednesday night at 9:30 on ABC.
Congratulations. It's a huge success.
And I'm so happy for you,
because you deserve everything
good in your life
- And you too.
- and you just put out the good,
and you are good, and this was so good.
(bright music)